you wanted a prup and she says nope I'm
not getting a prenup and then you said
okay yeah that's true why did you agree
at that time I'll find out whether this
was the right thing to do or not but a
lot of things in my life are still to be
played out and that could be one of the
most expensive decisions I ever made in
my life what would you say to your
daughter assri get a prup but it's the
love of her life and he says I don't
want a prenup I'm not getting married
she will absolutely get a prup how is
your wife different in that scenario we
never dreamed we would be where we're at
right now there's four or5 billion real
estate there's 11 companies that are
probably worth 3 or 4 billion I never
thought ever in my life time we would be
where we're at but we are and she has
participated and I hope this is never
used in a court of law against me but I
mean in a deposition I would have to say
yeah dude she participated she's been a
phenomenal partner child birth these two
guys without drugs at home without us
bringing them to hospital she's a
Warrior Man